[Music]
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know nothing
the unexamined life is not worth living
there is only one good knowledge and one
evil ignorance
[Music]
i cannot teach anybody anything i can
only make them think
wonder is the beginning of wisdom
be kind for everyone you meet is
fighting a hard battle
[Music]
strong minds discuss ideas average minds
discuss events weak minds discuss people
to find yourself think for yourself
[Music]
education is the kindling of a flame not
the filling of a vessel
[Music]
by all means mary if you get a good wife
you'll become happy if you get a bad one
you'll become a philosopher
[Music]
be slow to fall into friendship but when
you are in continue firm and constant
[Music]
he who is not contented with what he has
would not be contended with what he
would like to have
[Music]
the children now love luxury they have
bad manners contempt for authority they
show disrespect for elders and love
chatter in place of exercise
[Music]
sometimes you put walls up not to keep
people out but to see who cares enough
to break them down
know thyself
[Music]
let him who would move the world first
move himself
[Music]
when the debate is lost slander becomes
the tool of the loser
death may be the greatest of all human
blessings
the only good is knowledge and the only
evil is ignorance
[Music]
contentment is natural wealth luxury is
artificial poverty
[Music]
do not do to others what angers you if
done to you by others
[Music]
every action has its pleasures and its
price
employ your time in improving yourself
by other menace writings so that you
shall come easily by what others have
labored hard for
[Music]
no man has the right to be an amateur in
the matter of physical training it is a
shame for a man to grow old without
seeing the beauty and strength of which
his body is capable
i am not an athenian or a greek but a
citizen of the world as quoted in
plutarch s of banishment
[Music]
prefer knowledge to wealth for the one
is transitory the other perpetual
the hour of departure has arrived and we
go our separate ways i to die and you to
live which of these two is better only
god knows
[Music]
we cannot live better than in seeking to
become better
understanding a question is half an
answer
[Music]
envy is the ulcer of the soul
[Music]
beware the barrenness of a busy life
the hottest love has the coldest end
[Music]
be as you wish to see
from the deepest desires often come the
deadliest hate
[Music]
be nicer than necessary to everyone you
meet everyone is fighting some kind of
battle
thou should state to live not live to
eat
[Music]
the greatest way to live with honor in
this world is to be what we pretend to
be
[Music]
if you want to be a good saddler saddle
the worst horse for if you can tame one
you can tame all
[Music]
true wisdom comes to each of us when we
realize how little we understand about
life ourselves and the world around us
once made equal to man woman becomes his
superior
[Music]
i pray thee oh god that i may be
beautiful within
[Music]
the really important thing is not to
live but to live well and to live well
meant along with more enjoyable things
in life to live according to your
principles
[Music]
one should never do wrong in return nor
mistreat any man no matter how one has
been mistreated by him
[Music]
life contains but two tragedies one is
not to get your heart's desire the other
is to get it
the easiest and noblest way is not to be
crushing others but to be improving
yourselves
[Music]
if all our misfortunes were laid in one
common heap once everyone must take an
equal portion most people would be
content to take their own and depart
the beginning of wisdom is the
definition of terms
[Music]
he is richest who is content with the
least for content is the wealth of
nature
in all of us even in good men there is a
lawless wild beast nature which peers
out in sleep
[Music]
my friend care for your psyche know
thyself for once we know ourselves we
may learn how to care for ourselves
[Music]
children nowadays are tyrants they
contradict their parents gobble their
food and tyrannize their teachers
[Music]
the greatest blessing granted to mankind
come by way of madness which is a divine
gift
what screws us up the most in life is
the picture in our head of what it s
supposed to be
[Music]
be of good cheer about death and know
this of a truth that no evil can happen
to a good man either in life or after
death
think not this faithful who prays all
thy words and actions but those who
kindly reprove thy faults
[Music]
all men s souls are immortal but the
souls of the righteous are immortal and
divine
virtue does not come from wealth but
wealth and every other good thing which
men have comes from virtue
[Music]
through your rags i see your vanity
the highest realms of thought are
impossible to reach without first
attaining an understanding of compassion
to move the world we must move ourselves
[Music]
he who is unable to live in society or
who has no need because he is sufficient
for himself must be either a beast or a
god
not life but good life is to be chiefly
valued
i know you one t believe me but the
highest form of human excellence is to
question oneself and others
the mind is everything what you think
you become
[Music]
there is no solution seek it lovingly
the misuse of language induces evil in
the soul
living well and beautifully and justly
are all one thing
[Music]
when you want wisdom and insight as
badly as you want to breathe it is then
you shall have it
there is no greater evil one can suffer
than to hate reasonable discourse
[Music]
to express oneself badly is not only
faulty as far as the language goes but
does some harm to the soul
those who are hardest to love need it
the most
give me beauty and the inward soul may
the outward and the inward man be at one
it is better to change an opinion than
to persist in a wrong one
[Music]
is it true is it kind or is it necessary
he is not only idol who does nothing but
he is idol who might be better employed
be true to thine own self
[Music]
may the inward and outward man be as one
are you not ashamed of heaping up the
greatest amount of money and honor and
reputation
and caring so little about wisdom and
truth and the greatest improvement of
the soul
to know thyself is the beginning of
wisdom
[Music]
as to marriage or celibacy let a man
take which course he will he will be
sure to repent
a system of morality which is based on
relative emotional values is a mere
illusion a thoroughly vulgar conception
which has nothing sound in it and
nothing true
beauty is a short-lived tyranny
wealth does not bring about excellence
but excellence makes wealth and
everything else good for men both
individually and collectively
[Music]
wealth does not bring goodness but
goodness brings wealth and every other
blessing both to the individual and to
the state
my plainness of speech makes them hate
me and what is their hatred but a proof
that i am speaking the truth
such as thy words are such will thine
affections be esteemed and such as thine
affections will be thy deeds and such as
thy deeds will be thy life
[Music]
an unconsidered life is not one worth
living
how many things can i do without
[Music]
now the hour to part has come i go to
die you go to live which of us goes to
the better lot is known to no one except
the god
[Music]
as for me all i know is that i know
nothing for when i dante know what
justice is ill hardly know whether it is
a kind of virtue or not or whether a
person who has it is happy or unhappy
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to the
channel wisdom of the ages
[Music]
you